I filled it you kind of helped usher in
that you used to be you know when I
started watching the show when run it
back nobody knew when you what it was
really
except for older people watch it on PBS
so it's really been with Matt that
you've kind of brought it to the
forefront there how does it feel
you know spreading that well I mean not
actually as a longtime Doctor Who fan I
just I feel like I'm converting the
heathen and so it's I think yeah I think
what I mean they weren't even doing an
incredible job or promoting it so that's
what that's what's happened we've we've
had it we've now got you something
enough for episode since it came back of
saleable Doctor Who you know that some
of the old stuff it's beautiful I love
it more than anything but you can't
really sell it abroad map really you
know what I mean I'm not being me I love
it I think it's the best thing ever
after I do what I do but but the new
ones a lot of them know and a high
production value and and we're really
pushing I think when people see Doctor
Who they will like it or at least an
awful lot of people will like it because
he's real and I don't just mean the bits
idea I'm not I'm not saying that a
randomly boast I'm hanging from his
coattails in America we have we did we
went back to you in New York
yeah well it's always story driven a
story room so we went to we could see
who tell but I mean that originally were
running to go into Florida because it
was also but then about NASA and so on
until we discovered that Florida looks
exactly like Cardiff so I thought we can
do that you can do car live here is
company alligator on the phone we might
we might yeah it's possible love America
we love America yes yes
well III would be very worried about
having two doctors sharing the lunchbox
how does that work which of them is more
important than the other which is the
junior doctor which is the senior doctor
I'm not sure that works I think there
has to be one dr. Pereira
I think Paul McGann was superlative in
that I think do you know what I honestly
think he's gonna end up playing some big
old lady because I know he already has
that kind of thing but I think he showed
a flash of his leading man abilities we
seem quite in that dashing form for a
while
he's gonna end up doing something
interesting off the back of that no
question you know what's really
important with a night of the doctor
it's not that it was Paul McGann
brilliant as it was it's not that it's
that you had a bloody surprise you know
back in the day we used to do those so
don't spoil anything but you know I mean
that's what it was and I'd like to do
that again I liked III I think that will
usher in not not so much Paul McGann
miniseries it will usher in the idea
that when we when our little menace
orders would call them hideous name but
we call them that I think we should take
them more seriously than we used to and
that's the first one we've got is that I
said let's make let's make a belter
let's make a high production value belt
and let's give them a surprise
you could count on us doing something
but I get like that again but we won't
tell you when I'm not I've actually said
that I back told the BBC
if we do it again we're doing in Cardiff
no telling what we're doing and well I
will give you on the day right I won't
tell you anything
well I don't know yeah cuz he's barely
started but he's a genius he's a genius
actor no one knows not even
controversial to say he's a great love
of the part he's got the moment you
think is Peter Capaldi as the delta you
get it you see that face in the TARDIS
that works everybody gets that he's
going to eat just gonna give us a whole
new kind of doctor we've got used to I
suppose - brilliant iterations really
brilliant iterations of the younger a
more popular doctor and that's a real
part and that and they have both been
super elated now it's time to remain
that now it's time for the old beast to
snarl at you a bit I'd say I mean I mean
sometimes you see that in Matt's method
times as well sometimes
surely it will remind the people around
it I'm not really like this
well I think I think Peters doctor will
make that even clearer forget
disappointing for you and that you wants
to I didn't mind it going earlier I
didn't I just went on one of the Doctor
Who blog sites and sighs photograph then
I thought you bastards
because there were people in need of
people in you most of them had the
common human decency to to take their
mouths shut
but one or two people have to be show
offs and that was disappointing but but
then then but then it's sort of um it's
sort of rather work for us because I
said let's let's just let's just be mean
let's give my an hour let's just say in
an hour's time get to your iPlayer talk
to nobody and that was a good way of
doing it that's a bit more showbiz
that's all just that but you know
because the one point was that we should
call it - Paul McGann in the last
regeneration that would have had no
impact at all he'd have known what you
were going to see but about a whole
bunch of Doctor Who fans sitting down
click on their computers that there he
is possibly not the one you were
expecting and that was I was I was of
course involved in the show I did some
episodes that year that year I would
like to thank but but can't quite
convince myself that I would have done
exactly the same because what Russell
did was exactly right was exactly right
it was a precision piece of television
that in how he positioned Doctor Who
within the television landscape at the
time then no fantasy television no
family television nothing of that kind
existed and yet he phoned away to say
Doctor Who is cool and Doctor Who is for
you you know there was a tiny such a
Hollyoaks it was like you know it was
the doctor was a bloke you might meet in
the pub it was so so cleverly done I
certainly wouldn't be attempting to
improve him or Russell that or anything
muscles done you know
why do you think doctor is such a huge
huge following and also work we've had
50 years now where do you sleep going in
the next uh well I really knew how you
get a following like this I do it more
often a wholesome a job no III don't I
don't know I mean I think I think it has
uniquely the virtues have been very old
and brand new at the same time which is
an odd thing isn't it I mean every new
time maybe every time the doctor changes
we get a completely different version of
the same man so it simultaneously feels
as though it's a grand old tradition and
it also feels disconcertingly different
than you if you can combine those two
things at the same time be both
reassuring and alarming then then you've
got your hit television show I think
other shows should it should invent
regeneration believe me I've worked in
other shows where I wish there were the
possibility of regeneration and none of
them I'm working on so I think that's
that that is one part of it was it good
was it gonna go in the next 50 years
it's gonna go nowhere it's gonna stay
where it is I don't know that you know I
think there'll be times when it goes up
and down because everything does not
anytime soon as you can say but I think
but I think as a television myth as a
legend I think it is here to stay if if
doing what they did to it moronically
in 1989 when they tried to starve it
and even though actually was going
through a creative Renaissance they bend
it I mean who was doing quite strongly
against correlation street with no
publicity it still they got rid of it
and then he kept off the air for 50 for
16 years if that none worked I don't
know how you access what do you do white
people's memories it is the audience not
the TV that's not main are you who
decide what stays on television and the
audience have always been firm the
doctor who stays is going absolutely
nowhere and everyone has any president
has seen the anniversary they had the
sneak peek of definitely have runs
quickly through my head actually Matt
Smith hasn't seen it yet in 3d I think
had anyone seen that that ain't hang on
though we've sent it to 94 countries so
some people have seen it how the hell is
this not late hooray for worldwide no I
think that's the answer
absolutely no
doctor has seen it don't believe
everything you look have you not noticed
we've been gone a rodent seen any old
thing all of us the doctors of
disinformation that's all they are you
notice they're here come don't be so
gradual it's the only way we can keep
secrets and secrets are good wasn't it
great when Paul McGann who had
previously told you was definitely not
involved in any way popped up on your
screen wasn't that fun yeah we do more
of that let's just that's why we that's
why we wind you up a bit sometimes in
the nice and lovey-lovey way so that
you'll hopefully be a little bit more
entertained hopefully though all snarl
oh I mean you know reinventing and keep
staying true to the shows for
regeneration of you and maintaining that
sort of the core values the trouble is
if you look at Doctor Who all the bits
have changed it's like it is like the
broom and that with the handle and the
brush that have been changed repeatedly
so it always works that way at the last
time when I did all this the last time
with the new doctor I didn't have much
of a choice except make it look as
though we were being bold and changing
everything because you know what all the
exactly after the producer left both
stars left everybody left
we entry there was nothing we could do
except go for it just go for exact up
again and with super company we're
changing nothing else mummy it that was
it is not necessary to do that I mean
when when Peter's doctor comes in
there'll be several characters carrying
over from the previous era because they
look as they can be it was purely that I
didn't have a choice for that stuff it
worked but you know I had a future it
was nice and it slims year but you know
it was it's it's how difficult it is to
juggle that it's not I think Doctor Who
is fundamentally quite simple it's quite
simple it's a mannequin go anywhere in
time and space and have any face he
likes so you know and change is a
constant if you didn't change it then
you would not be even that be true too
it used to be oddly enough so kind of
having that blank slate oh yeah yeah
she's good and he's bad and he's
terrified bricking it may breaking it
well how do you think I feel we just
made a television show an apartment
sending to 94 countries and everyone in
the world has got I think an advanced
and sometimes angry opinion but what did
you be like and you know there is no
possibility that one show is gonna sum
up everything everyone wants from Doctor
Who but so terrified
yes terrified absolutely terrified but I
hope I think we've got a good show but
let's see but yeah bricking it would be
the word normally I will do that so we
shall go through that set of airlocks
normally right we are short to my mates
and this in then we talk to the cast and
crew and all that and then we show it to
the press and I stand up on Twitter
about spoilers and then we send it out
over the press and there's a grad and
you gradually get an impression of you
know where you are with this one is it
out is it a belter is it an LK one this
time nobody's in it and and an hour and
15 minutes after nobody's in it
everybody's in it I had no idea what
then happens do I have to go into hiding
but it's yes it's scary I thank God I
haven't anything else big coming up like
I don't know the doctor regenerating or
the reveal of how Sherlock survived
thank god that's not my next couple of
months
I mean tour aspects of Doctor Who are
sort of present in every Doctor Who
story that's that's the odd thing and
but but one of the core aspects of
Doctor Who is one man against the
universe one man there's one man who
makes a difference and now there's three
of them so it's actually in a in a
curious way the celebration episode is
different the core values are altered
like you could almost define Doctor Who
as the story doctor as the effect the
doctor has on the people he meets
whether it's the companion or the the
world he saves or the the villains he
overthrows it's his impact on them but
this special this reverses that is the
day of the doctor it's it's a story that
affects it as indeed it must be there's
three of the buggers I mean I'm talking
about introspective you know it's it's
an ego trip he's he's talking to himself
on a whole new level and one of them
sounds like John Hurt you know probably
my interior monologues were so classy I
mean I was always although I think he
sort of worked for a bit the exile death
I was always nervous of how you'd market
that know less time travel and less
space travel and he works in an office
you know and translates who inherited
that format
we're immediately taking it apart and
saying he can repair his TARDIS
sometimes and he can bugger off by the
time we get into the second or third
year of it he's spending as much time in
space as any other doctor but it did
give us one of the doctors great
friendships with the Brigadier and that
was and and the fact and it did place
front and center his ambiguous
relationship with combat and violence
and soldiers because although he claims
to be the world's greatest pacifist he
hasn't blown up more planets than anyone
you know
so I quite like that quite like the
contrast of this would-be hippie stuck
stuck among soldiers
it's a story-driven as oh absolutely
still a story-driven
it's if we come up with a good story I
mean the words bring back are among the
most regularly used ones among Doctor
Who fans that's not a story
that's just a moment I'm back and know
what so it's just a matter of if there's
a story I wrote his first month I don't
think it's so much informed but suffered
them before as informed and indeed
limited by what I always write about do
you know I mean it's IIIi I'm still me
and I'm still interest in the same thing
so these things sort of come up you know
I an obsession and interest in nonlinear
storytelling you know unleash that
unleash that man on us and her
time-travel show and you're in trouble
and so you have been that that never
bull I never think of the doctors being
in this verities I mean Matt Smith was
in his twenties and his thirties as the
doctor I never thought of them and I
never think of the doctor was young in
that sense he can be silly and youthful
and immature but I don't think I've I
think in the young Matt Smith didn't
play particularly young doctor he played
he played a man barking man boffin and
happen to have a young face that's just
skin look what we did to house you never
know coming up with the carriage of the
war doctor do you think John
well I sort of knew that what we were
going to end up doing was accounting for
those 16 years and it was just too
exciting the thought that there might
have been another doctor in there that
he never bothered to mention that was
that was just too thrilling not to do
once you thought of anything I'll go do
that so having done that for the end of
the name of the doctor to work whoever
turned around had to be awesome you know
if it was me that turned around that'd
be really awful if it was a some middle
middling actor turned down you know it
wouldn't it had to be somebody that you
always wished had played the doctor so
we thought he was the the first person
we thought of and the first person to be
offered it and what your I would you on
her it was he was around during doctor
who's like he's somebody when he's
almost Caligula it was I wish he could
be Doctor Who he'd be brilliant as
doctor and though he is we could do it a
special mayfly doctor one who's there
for one day and you get you know and for
the doctors birthday present he gets he
has to be played by John her screen
legend but you know at that moment at
the end of the name of the doctor is is
so cool because it's him
you know and weren't didn't we totally
underlying our achievement John Hurt as
the doctor what did him again no because
then I mean that happened to the doctor
twice in my own sense of cannon would go
to pieces I will visit wouldn't he know
we done all this before hey aren't we
repetitive enough for you no I wouldn't
IIIi like to think of all the Doctor Who
story yeah it's Walden big story and he
shouldn't do the same story twice
you